如果现在是越来越觉得我们作为普通人，
作为平凡的人，
就是平安的健康的度过这一生，
就是最大的胜利，
如果能够一家人和和美美的彼此依偎的，
能平安的健康的度过这一生，
就是巨大的胜利。
现在我面临的就是两地分居的问题，
我们想解决两地分居的问题，
但是现在有一些困难，
一个呢，
就是我老公他是南方的本地的人，
他现在是创业，
关于他自己创业呢，
他项目呀，
关系啊什么的，
对人脉可能都各方面相对来说比较有前景，
目前还没有太做起来，
我自己呢，
因为我本身是跟他在这个同一个省，
就南方的一个高校里面，
后来之后我就出来读博了，
读博完了之后呢，
我现在又找到了长三角的一个高校的工作，
关于我自己这个工作吧，
我较喜欢吧，
也比较对口，
但是呢，
遇到困难，
他评职称，
反正现在都很卷嘛，
比较难，
比较调动到南方的高校呢，
因为我之前也是一直想往回本省的这方向去找，
但是就是他们反正各方面的要求也比较高，
就没有过去，
如果我要从这边辞职回去，
没有满合同时间，
也需要赔钱，
但是这个方面我觉得如果能找到好的合适的学猩，
可能我也愿意赔。
现在是这个工作，
我自己又比较喜欢，
又比较符合我的专业，
所以面临这样的问题，
还有关于孩子的问题，
因为孩子嘛，
现在在这个南方的城市，
他比较小，
现在才一年级，
但是呢，
他面临这种以后有高考红利嘛，
我又舍不得让他到长三角这边来卷，
压力又比较大。
再一个我们家的情感问题呢，
我感觉是非常的和谐，
我们也相互支撑，
也走了15年了，
相互作为支柱，
所以面临分居问题，
不知道如何去解决，
大概就是这样的情况，
看看您能给什么建议，
就他那头收入是什么情况呀，
其实他嗯没有太稳定的收入，
有项目就做，
可能遇到小项目呢，
几万块钱，
如果遇到大项目呢，
可能就比较多，
大概是这样的情况，
不稳定的，
那你们现在有多少存款呢？
我们流动资金的话可能就不到20吧，
什么安18也安过来，
在南方的省现在有两套房，
但也是在南方的老家省会，
那你现在跟他距离，
如果说坐高铁的话，
几个小时啊，
它是沿海嘛，
他是要过海，
所以没有高铁，
只能坐飞机，
你会来回的路程的话四五个小时，
你们俩等于是你在你的城市也没有买房子，
他在他工作那个城市也没有买房子，
房子是买在他的老家是吧，
他工作的城市就是他的。
小家我们在工作的城市以及他现在工作的城市买的房子就同一个城市，
原来一切都还比较和谐，
但是原来我自己对我这个工作特别的难受，
所以我就出来读博了，
读博了之后，
那你现在收入怎么样，
我想换一个更好一点的高校嘛，
你现在收入怎么样呢？
之后其实也不高，
可能大概5000块钱左右，
如果是这样的话，
第一你们夫妻感情很好，
第二你老公在他现在工作的这个城市，
也就是他老家也买了两套房了，
第三孩子也是在那边上学，
那我觉得像这种情况下的话，
你应该努力带孩子上学，
那个地方的话再找找那些学校，
可能未必有你现在这个学校那么级别高啊，
哪怕说找一个那种三流的四流的学校都可以啊，
其实一开始是有这个机会，
但是我自己呢，
因为我在之前的那个高校吧，
呆的特别的难受，
在一个专业不符合，
读完博之后就特别想找一个能够符合我自己专业的这样的这个单位，
所以现在找到符合专业的单位呢，
就不能够两全家里的问题，
我只是说从我的这个角度来考虑这个问题的话，
我可能还是要多给孩子一点陪伴吧，
错过了就是错过了，
仅供你参考啊，
因为如果你能在老公那个家乡找到这。
呃，
位置有一个高效的工作的话，
你现在又是博士的身份，
如果你在自己的工作上能够做出成绩的话，
还是很有建树的，
或者说很有被重视的，
不然的话，
你现在一个月5000块钱的收入，
在你所在的长三角，
其实我觉得生活也是很贫瘠的，
确实是的，
但是我自己因为一开始我在高校里来，
我就原来那个高校，
因为不符合自己专业，
我会过得很难受，
就感觉自己没有平台，
没有发展，
只能够停留在那里，
那也是一种很煎熬的状态，
可是你现在也没有很好的发展啊，
我说句难听的话，
你现在你也没有拿出什么成绩啊，
但是我现在只能够做跟我自己专业相关的事情，
可能我自己会做的比较开心，
我自己是想的说，
如果能够拿到好一些的成绩的话，
再调回去可能会相对容易一些，
但是事实就是现在评职称的各种方面其实都很困难，
都很全，
竞争都很大，
我不知道我现在该何去何从，
如果我回去的话，
可能我也基本上为零的可能性能够找到跟我自己相关的专业的工作。
我讲的只是我自己的一些人生的感觉啊，
我觉得夫妻两口子感情又很好，
孩子又是在读书，
其实我坦率的说啊，
大家都是普通人，
都很平凡的人。
真的，
我们做这份工作几乎上没有什么意义，
我知道如果跳出来的话，
确实是这样的，
有舍有得吧，
看取舍，
如果是您的话，
可能就往回走是吗？
因为你在高校干的这个工作，
坦率的说啊，
你在长三角干和在沿海地区干，
对这个社会没有太大的影响，
没有太大的意义，
太社会是没有太大意义，
从经济上对家庭的贡献也不大，
对孩子的帮助也不大，
就没有太大的区别，
唯一就是受益的，
其实就是我自己的心情方面，
工作，
工作的氛围跟我自己的这种感受方面，
或许是我很自私吧，
但是我又很像两全，
但是两全的问题好像又很难解决，
仅供你参考，
好不好，
好，
谢谢，
就这样啊，
拜拜啊。
其实我现在是越来越觉得我们作为普通人，
作为平凡的人，
就是平安的健康的度过这一生，
就是最大的胜利。
如果能够一家人和和美美的，
彼此依偎的，
能平安的健康的度过这一生，
就是巨大的胜利。
我现在是这种感受，
你不管看美剧也好，
看各种各样的电视剧也好，
每一个层次的人，
他都有他自己的内好，
都还想往上一个层次再去爬，
再去蹦，
但是结果到头来都是一切皆为空，
万事皆空，
只有你所经历的这些喜怒哀。
色的记忆，
你所感受到的这些幸福的瞬间，
可能是真真切切你活过的证明。
至于我们对这个社会毫无意义，
我不知道我这么说谁能懂我这个点，
包括我自己，
我也知道像我这样的人对这个社会没有意义，
对人类也没有什么贡献，
我们努力的平平安安度过这一生，
就是巨大的胜利啊。
刚刚有的人说，
不，
你对我们有意义啊，
我们看从你的层级来看待这个问题啊，
在我的价值体系里面，
我觉得那些为女性争取到同工同酬，
为女性争取到平等的继承权，
为女性争取到上班的资格，
为女性争取到婚姻自由的权利，
为女性争取到身体堕胎权，
自己怀孕生孩子自己能决定的权利，
为女性就解除了一些家锁的这些人，
他们是真的对这个社会有意义、
有价值推动的人，
我是这么理解这件事情的，
但像我们屏幕前的1万人和龙飞，
我们都是平凡的普通人，
我们做这一份工作其实对这个社会是没有意义的。
记得点赞关注哦。